RACHEL BEEN: I'd like to
introduce our panelists.
To begin with, we
have Mark Kawano.
Mark is the CEO and
co-founder of Storehouse,
maker of the visual
storytelling app
that's won Apple's
2014 design awards.
Previously, Kawano
held design leadership
at frog, Adobe, and
most recently, Apple
where he served as User
Experience Evangelist
and was responsible
for designing
apps such as
Aperture and iPhoto.
Next up is Tyson Evans.
Tyson is an editor on
the newsroom strategy
team at the New York Times.
Previously, he was
the deputy editor
of The Times
interactive news desk,
working with a
team of developers
to build data-driven
web apps on deadline.
He is also an adjunct professor
at Columbia University's
Graduate School of Journalism.
Next up is Dustin Senos.
Dustin currently works at
Medium as the Head of Design.
He's passionate about creating
rewarding interactions
between humans and technology
through prototyping, quick
iterations, and
empathizing with users.
Mike Renaud is the Creative
Director for Pitchfork.
He lead a team that designs
the website in addition
to their two festivals
in Paris and Chicago,
their venture into film
called The Dissolve,
and most recently, a
quarterly print publication,
The Pitchfork Review.
These endeavors have
received many Webby awards,
the 2013 National Magazine
award for digital excellence,
and a spot for Michael on
Ad Age's Creativity 50 list.
And last but not least,
we have Maykel Loomans.
He's a product
designer at Facebook.
Previously, Michael was at
Instagram for three years.
His work ranges from
design, to prototyping,
to actually writing
code that ships.
Originally hailing
from the Netherlands,
he now lives in
San Francisco where
he enjoys exploring and
photographing the city
and beyond.
So with that, let's get into it.
So, visual storytelling.
Extremely buzzy words.
Let's define it.
First off, how do
you individually
define visual storytelling
for the specific products
that you work on?
And really, why
are your products
visual storytelling products?
Let's start with Maykel.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: I think
visual storytelling
is the nonverbal way to enhance
whatever text is around it.
And with Instagram, like
Instagram is inherently
a communication product.
But the medium that we
use is square photos.
And this really just
enhances that the photo
is the key element that captures
you, but the text around it
is actually like the
context of that photo.
So the visual aspect just
enhances the platform.
And by being visual first,
that works really well.
MICHAEL RENAUD: Yeah, you're
right, it's a buzzy word.
I'm not sure exactly
how to define that now
because there's always
been visual storytelling.
So, I think for us, we actually
look to the past a lot more
than we do to the
future in some ways.
It's really nice to
have technologies
where we can use big photos
and lots of illustrations
and everything.
But when it comes down to
it, it's just an opportunity
now to be able to tell
those kind of stories
on the web the way we have
been in a lot of other mediums
in the past.
RACHEL BEEN: Great.
DUSTIN SENOS: For us
at Medium, we kind of
look at visual
storytelling as a way
of letting people share
their thoughts and ideas
and building tools in a platform
for letting them take advantage
of modern technology.
With video embeds,
pictures, modern typefaces.
And putting a lot of weight on
presentation of the content.
TYSON EVANS: And I
would say at the Times,
it's just an aspect of our
larger journalistic mission.
So the idea of
visualizing the news
is baked into something
that's inherently visual,
like a huge narrative story,
like Snow Fall or something.
But also a part of things that
are less obviously visual.
So, a push alert or
election results tonight.
Like, what is the story
of these other types
of ways of conveying the news?
MARK KAWANO: Pretty
good definitions
of visual storytelling.
At Storehouse, it's
pretty similar.
It's just how to communicate
a lot of information
using images.
So photos, videos, graphics.
Whether it's something
of where you are,
what you're seeing using
those types of media
rather than just text
or words to communicate
that information.
RACHEL BEEN: Great.
I want to take a moment just
to click through and also
showcase some of the products
that you guys specifically
are working on.
Storehouse, for Mark.
New York Times cross platform.
Medium for Dustin.
Mike on the Pitchfork Review
among multiple other products.
And Instagram.
So to talk a little more about
quality, curation, social,
these kind of aspects
of visual storytelling.
Is really good design on a lot
of these products-- which you
all work on very well,
designed platforms--
potentially hiding bad content?
Dustin, I want to
start with you.
Medium is a beautifully
designed platform.
Do you think it's making
bad content inconspicuous
to some degree?
DUSTIN SENOS: We talk about
that a lot internally.
And our take is
what is bad content?
Just because I don't
particularly enjoy something
that someone has written
doesn't mean it's bad.
We try to not
choose what is good.
design in a way that
makes bad content look good.
Because if you want
to tell a story,
or want to share an idea,
we don't want the interface
to try to push you in
one direction or bait
and switch you.
Like, oh this story
looks fantastic
but the content is
actually horrible.
We don't have an
opinion on that.
We try to be agnostic to
the actual content being
made on our platform.
So we just try to elevate
the content that you create
and just try to put our
design chops toward something
that people otherwise
couldn't do on their own.
And as far as what's
actually the type of content,
we try not to say
what's good or bad.
MICHAEL RENAUD: Yeah, I mean,
it's obviously a trendy term,
again.
But I think that design has
gotten in the way a lot.
Even if the story's
bad, I think the fact
that people are trying to kind
of go down this road a lot,
it's sort of gotten in the way
of what you're trying to read.
It's distracting
in a lot of ways.
So, I think it's
important for all of us
to sort of keep that in
mind and keep ourselves
in check in terms of trying to
get too far ahead of ourselves.
And I don't know,
designers a lot of times
have a tendency to
want to show themselves
off more than the content.
So I think that
could be a problem.
But the reason we
started doing it
the first place
was because we're
doing these huge features.
We're spending a lot of
money on sending people out
to do interviews and we're
really proud of how we did.
And then they'd be
gone in three days.
They'd be down on
the homepage, people
would stop tweeting about them.
And it was kind of
frustrating for us.
So on our end, we kind of
wanted to bring more attention
to these things, just
because we thought
they were more impactful than
just the regular old thing.
RACHEL BEEN: Even this concept
of not even hiding bad content,
but potentially a fine line
between superfluous design
in more bigger experiences
such as the Pitchfork
cover stories or even the
New York Times Snow Fall.
There's been obviously
a lot of talk
about the design, the code,
the implementation potentially
covering up or not
allowing people
to actually read the content.
Tyson, I don't
know if you'd want
to address this concept of maybe
that's part of the storytelling
experience at this point.
TYSON EVANS: Yeah,
I mean, I think
there's a couple of
things at work there.
First, I think we all have
faced the same challenge of,
what signals can we
convey to readers to say
that this is worth
your attention?
And then it's this
kind of constant battle
to keep their attention
throughout that process.
Whether it's a narrative
story, an interactive story,
a reader-driven story, we
all face the same challenge
of what levers are we going
to pull that both signal right
off the bat that this is
something to invest your time
and energy into.
But also, maybe
participate with.
That's that second piece of a
lot of our projects right now.
Just saying, here's a
front door that tells you
a story that's something
worth your attention.
But take the last Sunday
magazine of the Times
every year, it's this
beautiful tribute to the lives
that we lost over the year.
Beautiful obituaries, beautiful
photos, beautiful remembrances.
And we use that as a
kind of an open door
to ask people to share
their memories back with us.
And we present those
back at the same stage
with the same level of editing,
and care, and thoughtfulness,
and photo editing,
and written editing.
So, I think it ends up kind of
being this two-way street where
you're trying to create
enough signals up front.
But also create
these opportunities
for the unexpected to happen.
MARK KAWANO: Yeah,
I think it starts
with defining what design is.
I think there's
two aspects of it.
There's the visual side
and some of the animations
that we're starting to
see in modern software.
But then there's also the
design of how something works.
And what we've tried to really
strive for at Storehouse
is the content is what
you're looking at.
We've tried to remove almost
all chrome from our interface
and really just putting
that content on display.
And that's the
design that we see.
Even the typefaces
that we've chosen,
we've to be as neutral as
possible so that the photos
and videos and whatever
the actual author's
trying to convey, that's
the actual visual design
or visual aesthetic
aspect of it.
And so our design actually
goes into the background.
And I think that finding that
balance of how the system works
versus what it looks
like and how it feels
is just important for all
designers to consider.
RACHEL BEEN: That actually
leads into my next question
about the democratization
of the design
to allow both professional
and social content to live.
This panel is somewhat
divided in more
of professional,
traditional journalism
with user-generated content
and social journalism.
That dichotomy between
social and professional,
is that something that we
need to define as a dichotomy?
Are those things overlapping
and intermixing at this point?
Tyson, do you want to talk about
that specifically for the New
York Times?
TYSON EVANS: Yeah,
it's totally shifting.
Today, versus six
years ago at the Times,
users are way more woven into
the fabric of the report.
Our value as a
brand is very much
our editing and our judgment
and our ordering of the world.
But we're finding that
readers are obviously
kind of front line
in that system.
So, you take something
like this huge series
we've done for the last year
about the cost of healthcare
in the U.S. How
medical procedures here
can be exponentially larger in
cost and time and complications
than they are around the world.
And that's a series
that was almost entirely
driven by reader sourcing.
So, readers sharing
their stories
in a really structured way.
So, that was a design
challenge in the sense
that you don't want
just an empty text
box at the bottom of an article.
Throughout the story
we wove in prompts
to say, how old are you?
Are you insured?
Have you had a pregnancy?
What was the cost
of your pregnancy?
Where do you live?
And so you have this really rich
way of dividing and filtering
the comments on
a story that one,
make it a reading
experience for someone else
to find their story in the
cacophony of other stories.
But also, let the
reporter then use
that as the foundation for
their next piece of the series.
RACHEL BEEN: And Maykel,
for a product like Instagram
it's interesting because
you do you have obviously
an incredible social presence.
That's kind of the primary
focus of what Instagram is.
But you also are seeing
professional photojournalists
and photographers
using that platform
for money-making means.
In terms of the design
of that platform,
was there ever a
consideration-- I
guess this goes for
all the panelists
who alter some of the
design, some of the tools,
the content management systems,
to prioritize professionals
over more social journalists
or amateurs, to some extent.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: Yeah, I think
one of the most important
things that Instagram
as a product did
was just democratize how ever
your photo looked for anyone.
So businesses, professionals,
budding photographers,
they all look the same.
They all have the same
tools to work with.
And the freedom of the product
allowed them to actually
either become a
professional photographer,
or tell their story.
Contrary to a
Storehouse, Instagram
is like a one photo
platform right now.
And it's actually
the body of work
that tells more of the story.
Or it's a combination of
photos from different people
in the same location
that tell a story.
Just by the simplicity
of the product,
we kind of leave it at
the level playing field
and everyone gets to do
with it what they want.
So as I said before, we have the
professional photographers now
that started as amateurs
or just enthusiasts.
And they now have a
platform and a voice
that businesses and companies
are trying to chime in on.
Large companies like
Ford and other companies
are just trying to chime
in on their user base
and their presence
and their voice.
RACHEL BEEN: And we were
talking about this on Medium.
Now you have President
Obama writing on Medium.
Do you specialize tools
for him or allow him
a greater particular
presence because
of the nature of who he is?
And from a design
perspective, how do you
balance those two things?
DUSTIN SENOS: So at Medium,
we have internal publications
and we work with people like
President Obama and the White
House.
And we kind of use them to help
us as designers in the company
learn how a publication would
actually want to use the tools.
And we'll absolutely internally
build tools for publications
and then take pieces that are
working and learn from that
and then build it into
the rest of the platform
for other people.
So we're actually using it
as a learning opportunity
to see how a typical newsroom
or a typical book agency
would actually want the tools.
And then build that,
take pieces from that.
And we actually question
that a lot because we wonder
if the tools people
are asking for
are tools that
they're used to using,
but it's not
actually the best way
to publish content and actually
go through the editing process.
So along the whole
path, we're not saying,
oh that's what you've been
using for the last 15 years?
We'll build the same
thing in Medium.
We're questioning and trying
to iterate all that ourselves.
And it gives us a good
chance-- I've never
worked at a news
agency, I've never
written a book-- it gives
us a good opportunity
to learn what people expect
and how we can help them.
RACHEL BEEN: Do you have
something to add, Mike?
MICHAEL RENAUD: I guess the
only thing that comes to mind,
we don't offer that obviously.
But if we're talking about as
designers imposing limitations
on things so these types
of things come out better,
I think limitations
is a good thing
to keep in mind for everything.
And we're gatekeepers
of that, in a sense.
So, to use native
advertising as an example.
It's great that brands
can tell a story.
But at the same time, I think
that's a slippery slope,
personally.
And letting everyone in
on that, in a certain way,
there are other problems
that can come up
with that on the editorial level
that worry me a little bit.
And I think that's nothing
we can look at our ad people
about and expect
them to help us with.
And I think the same
goes for editorial.
They may not be as prone to
understanding that inclusion.
So I think as designers,
imposing limitations
on the outside,
if you're working
for an editorial entity,
is a responsibility of ours
for sure.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: That
actually ties into Instagram
where an ad is only the same
visual presence except that it
has a sponsored icon
on the top right.
And by just giving them the
same tools to play with,
if the person who uses the
app just scrolls through it,
it doesn't necessarily make
them go, oh shit, an ad!
So, by making sure that
the content is great
and that it fits
in on their feed,
that's how we have a good ad.
The whole purpose here is
to enhance your experience
by showing you content
that you didn't originally
intend by filtering
your followers.
And so by actually making
that fit in and giving them
these limitations,
I think that we're
trying to do the best job there.
MICHAEL RENAUD: Yeah, totally.
If we have all these tools now
where we can tell the stories,
why can't we work on
the ad side as well
to make beautiful ad
options for advertisers
that aren't native advertising?
That aren't infiltrating
our editorial.
Thinking on that side of things
as well is huge, totally.
RACHEL BEEN: To jump
ahead and add on
to that-- that's
a great point-- is
how are we monetizing things?
How do we monetize
in the future?
What's the future
of monetization?
And specifically on
social platforms,
who should actually be
getting paid, to some degree?
DUSTIN SENOS: It's
a great question.
We have a team actively
thinking of different ways
to monetize Medium.
Right now we're playing
with native advertisements.
We launched a branded
design collection
that was hosted by BMW.
And we have a very high bar
where the standard is, do we
want to read this content?
Because if not, then why are
we putting it on our platform,
and why would we
pay for the content
to be put on our platform?
I would love to
see a world where
if I have a good story to tell
and people are enjoying it,
I can be paid for that.
I don't think anyone's
figured that out yet.
And I think it's something
we're all striving for.
Especially on a platform like
Medium where anyone can write.
How do we attract top
writers to come here
if they can't be paid?
There's more than just
recognition they want.
People need to make
a living off of this.
RACHEL BEEN: Right.
And then the question of
who should be getting paid.
Is it the institution
or is it the individual?
DUSTIN SENOS: Totally.
RACHEL BEEN:
Obviously, the Times
has talked a lot
about monetization
and the pay wall, et cetera.
Can you share some
of what's going on
in terms of monetization
with the Times?
TYSON EVANS: Yeah.
At the core for us, we have
our two revenue streams
which are almost
50-50 at this point.
Our advertising
and subscriptions.
And those have very different
design constraints and goals
that are spoked around them.
So, across print
and the web, I think
we have more than two million
people as paying subscribers
at this point.
And they demand an experience
and a connection functionality
that isn't the same
as what would happen
if we were a purely
advertising-driven site.
So there's that kind of
built-in dichotomy of when we're
embarking on any
new feature, we're
kind of forced to ask ourselves
what is the revenue goal here?
Does there need to be one?
You take something
like our cooking app
which just launched on
the web and on the iPad.
That's a play that we made
that was purely about audience.
We really wanted to try to
reach as many people who maybe
haven't been exposed to
the Times recipe database.
And then we'll learn from that.
That is more the
exception for us.
It's rare that we
as a big company
can embark on
something new and say,
we're just doing this for
audience growth right now.
So the short answer is, it's
unclear and it's shifting.
And I don't think anyone
would have thought
we would've been 50%
percent subscriber supported
by this point.
And so who knows what five
or 10 years will bring.
RACHEL BEEN: And for you, Mark,
you're a fairly new product.
And Storehouse is completely
free to use and create stories.
Can you share with us
some of your thought
process behind that revenue?
MARK KAWANO: Yeah.
I think how creators get paid is
a really tricky question right
now.
I think the reality is,
what we're focusing on
and I think what a lot of other
panelists are focusing on,
is really just
opening up new ways
of communication amongst folks.
And we're at the early stage
of figuring out how that works,
what it looks like,
which people want it,
do they want it to be for
professional, personal?
And I think we're kind of
finding that the answer is
a little bit of everything right
now in some of those items.
And so our approach
at Storehouse
is really trying to focus
on that problem of how
do you communicate?
Who are the audiences?
How do we hone that craft?
With the idea that
if we do unlock
a lot of different relationships
between people and connections,
that's an extremely
valuable proposition
and there's ways for lots of
different people to get paid.
I don't think it's going
to be a single format.
I think with just
different types of content,
there's different verticals.
As you mentioned,
education or useful content
you can look at again
and again is something
that you might want to pay for.
Versus something that's
more topical or maybe harder
is not something
where you want to pay
or even advertisers would
want to associate themselves
with that.
There's got to be
some models there.
But I think it's just that we're
at such an early stage of all
of this visual
storytelling that it's
going to be really interesting
to see where it is.
But that's not our
focus right now.
RACHEL BEEN: I think there's
an interesting transition there
between this idea of
platform and publisher.
Obviously, something
like Medium.
We were talking recently
that Medium originally
launched as a platform to kind
of host other people's content.
But then it is now getting into
kind of the publishing game.
I'm interested in hearing
from you about that transition
as well as from
Mike from Pitchfork.
Traditionally, you've
always been a publisher.
Would you ever open it to
a social platform as well?
DUSTIN SENOS: Yes.
So on Medium-- I
like this question
because when we launched so many
people were like, what are you?
Are you a platform?
And internally, we were
like, do we have to pick?
Why do we have to
choose this right now?
What does it matter?
And we are absolutely both.
We have internal publications,
we have an editorial team
in New York, we have
creative directors
in San Francisco helping
create content on our platform,
and we use it as
a way to showcase
what you can do on Medium.
A way to stretch the product so
we're like constantly working
with editors and
illustrators to be
like, what features
would you like?
It just really helps
to guide us to see
how far can we
stretch this product
and how can we learn from it.
And then, what I
love is the fact
that we're building
and paying people
to help us build this very
expansive publishing platform
and then giving it
to people for free.
You can sign up and
use the same tools
as everyone else for free.
And I don't struggle
with if we're
a platform or a publisher.
I don't see why we need
to make that dichotomy.
And when we launched and people
wrote news articles about that,
it was like, oh, I
wonder why they're even
talking about that.
I can understand
from the perspective
of if you're writing on Medium
and we're only sharing content
that we are producing
and paying for,
versus shared social content.
But we try to just surface
content that's good.
And by adding our
social layer, it's
mostly driven by your
social graph now.
RACHEL BEEN: What do you think,
Mike, from your perspective?
MICHAEL RENAUD: We on our side,
discovering music on the web
has mostly been about
aggregation and finding music
through different
modes of social.
And for us, we've always thought
of ourselves more as a filter.
So just having an
editorial voice
that people have an expectation
when they come to this site.
We've never had comments
on the site either.
So, part of that for us has
been, let's keep it in house
and let's keep it ourselves.
But with that said, what you're
doing is really inspiring.
And I think there's
other ways down the line
where those things
could be incorporated.
Because our fans are a
huge part of what we do.
Obviously, we have
the music festival.
And that's a good
way for us to connect
with those people
individually and in person.
So, it's never anything
that's out of the question.
But traditionally, for us,
we've always thought of it
as just being a very
traditional editorial entity.
RACHEL BEEN: I think there's
a brand question in this.
We were talking
about for Instagram,
what is the brand of
Instagram, per se,
when it really isn't
Instagram's content?
I'm curious what you
think of that, Maykel,
in terms of how does brand
relate to this idea of simply
being a platform or being sort
of a hybrid publisher slash
platform?
MAYKEL LOOMANS: Yeah,
I think that Instagram
very early on got
a blog and used
that to start highlighting
important accounts.
So, accounts that
we thought were
very interesting to follow.
That was kind of
very early stage
and it's still one of the
things that we are currently
just exploring.
And the body of work
only becomes bigger.
There's others, like us
dipping toes in the water.
Like, we have these
small books now.
We launched a brand book
and a community book where
we, in print, start highlighting
all these interesting accounts
and interesting people that
have been making great photos
and have been telling stories.
For example, like
maddieonthings,
this hound that
stands on everything.
That's one of the stories
that we've been telling.
I think Instagram
as a company is
trying to figure out where it
fits in in actually publishing
its own content and
having its own voice.
There is an editor-in-chief
on the team now.
But that's all
very early stages.
And I think in the next
year, next two years,
we're going to see something
very interesting happen there.
RACHEL BEEN: Tyson, do
you think the Times will
open up and become
more of a platform?
TYSON EVANS: Yeah, I
think it already has been.
We're a site that's had a
heavily moderated comment
section now for eight years.
And there's amazing gems
in our comments section.
It's like the exact inverse of
the typical internet comment
section.
But it still feels secondary,
it still feels reactionary to us
as a publisher.
So one of the big projects
we're working on this year
is we're working with the
Washington Post and the Knight
Foundation and trying to
split that model a little bit
and put readers
a little bit more
at the forefront of
that interaction.
We've definitely done
it in sporadic one-offs.
Like, on the
anniversary of 9/11 we
asked readers to
drop a pin on a map
and tell us where they
were 10 years prior.
And there's kind of
a whole collection
of stories like that.
The thing we haven't done that
I'm so jealous of everyone else
up here having
figured out, is how
to create that as
just the rhythm
and expectation of the site.
And that's where we're
way more a publisher
than we are a platform.
RACHEL BEEN: I have a
question about distribution.
Let's talk about
quality a little bit.
This idea of distribution.
You can create a
beautifully curated piece,
but is the quality of
the content as good
as the distribution?
I know, Mark, we were talking
a little bit about this.
Of how to get content out there.
Potentially, now that's
almost more important.
Socialized content versus
the actual content itself.
Almost back to this
idea of beautiful design
covering bad content.
Is being social, being
viral, potentially
covering a lot of bad content?
MARK KAWANO: It's
a tricky thing.
We talk a lot about
what makes a story good
and what makes content good.
Is there something
intrinsic to it?
Or is it that if it
gets a lot of views,
then that's good because
people enjoy that
and it's getting
a lot of feedback?
I think it's a very
personal question.
It's pretty complicated.
The reality is,
distribution hasn't
been available to enough
people and it still
isn't available to
enough people today.
And the creation
tools aren't there.
As we think about professional
versus social content,
one of the great things that's
happened with the internet
is there's been
ways now for people
to get whatever their story
is, wherever they may be,
if they have an internet
connection, to convey that
to a whole bunch of people.
And we want to make that
more elegant and easier.
But we have such a
far way to go as far
as just distribution of
information amongst people.
And it's still very
highly concentrated
amongst a very select
few people on this world.
And I think that's part of what
we're all focusing on here.
DUSTIN SENOS: Yeah.
And at Medium, we noticed a
lot of people write a draft
but never click Publish.
And they're fearful of
the distribution side
because storytelling is
such a personal thing.
It's hard to write, it's hard
to open yourself up like that.
And it's something
we think a lot about.
Is it the audience?
Is it really who
you're writing for?
Is it the distribution
channel that makes it easier?
Will you be more likely
to write if you know,
I'm writing to six people
versus just putting it
on the internet for everyone
to read and judge your words?
RACHEL BEEN: And Mike, for you.
I mean, obviously, distribution.
You have festivals, there's
a print publication.
Do you find that this
kind of increases
the knowledge of
Pitchfork to some degree?
MICHAEL RENAUD: Yeah, sure.
That definitely helps
people be aware of the brand
and it helps people understand
what we're trying to do.
On the editorial
side on the website,
we try really hard to not
go too listical and Buzzfeed
and everything when it
comes to distribution.
Because we're just trying
to put good things out there
in the world.
Our print magazine is
a good example of that.
It's something that, I think,
hopefully enhances the brand.
Helps people understand
where we're coming from.
We write a lot more
about older music
and have great
photography and comments
and those types of things.
And from there is
where we expect
to hopefully find success.
But we don't ever want to
cannibalize our own editorial
efforts by putting things
out there just to drive up
the Likes on
Facebook or whatever.
RACHEL BEEN: And then one
last point on distribution
from the Times perspective.
So the innovation
report came out.
Leaked, some degree.
And there's an
interesting point in there
that basically said,
although we must always
polish our journalism,
we can have
some rough edges around
the way that we're
reaching new audiences.
Can you kind of talk
about what does that mean?
MICHAEL RENAUD: I
think it was also
a line in the report--
which I didn't work on,
so I can be fully critical
of-- but actually,
in the support of this idea
that the traditional publisher
model is you hit publish,
and then your job is done.
That's when you've finished
your work for the day.
Which, as we now know,
is totally false.
And most of the real reach
of what's going to happen
is what happens after
you hit Publish.
So one of our
biggest initiatives
right now is this idea of how
do we reach the audience that we
think is actually
interested in this work?
There was a video we
had, I think, last month
which was this incredible
video interview
with the sole survivor
of a massacre from ISIS.
And it was heart
wrenching, it was brutal.
And we realized,
that's the material
that we have to spend the
most amount of time trying
to find a natural audience for.
So we translated it into Arabic,
we published it in the morning
in the Middle East.
We tried to find distribution
partners and amplifiers
in a way that we
don't always do.
So I think those are
the levers that we're
trying to find
smarter ways to use.
And that is very
much the inverse
of how we used to operate.
RACHEL BEEN: So I want to talk
a little bit about the dichotomy
that you've all
heard because you
work in storytelling products.
Long-form versus short-form.
Firstly, is this sort
of an antiquated phrase
to some extent?
And also, just in
general, is something
like a single photo on
Instagram as powerful
as a full piece on Storehouse.
I want to talk about
this dichotomy.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: Yeah, I think
the execution of the story
is just based on what the
content of the story is.
So if within one photo you can
show this bomb that went off
in Syria-- like, early
on in Instagram's life,
we found this guy
named SyrianDeveloper.
And he was on the ground as
one of the few people taking
photos in Syria.
That one photo was
iconic and eventually got
so much distribution that
it became a story in itself.
And other outlets tried
to find context to it.
Having specifically
a larger article
around that originally
from the Instagram platform
I don't think would have
worked as well because that
was a in-the-moment,
right now experience
that needed to get into the
world as fast as possible.
Now, on the other hand, if you
want to give context to that,
I think a platform like
Storehouse or the Times
or Medium would be perfect
to actually do that.
It's kind of the story
within a larger story,
so you need those
strong elements.
So I think it's a combination
of many different things.
Just as a person shares
differently to Facebook
than they share to
Instagram than they tweet,
or that they would write
an article on Medium.
RACHEL BEEN: And Mark, for
you, is that a silly phrase?
We were talking about this.
MARK KAWANO: I think it's up to
the creator to kind of decide
how they want to communicate
their information.
And sometimes I wish people
would take more photos
from some of their Storehouse
stories when I look at them.
And when I look at
Instagram, I often
wish I could see a lot more
than just a single photo.
And I think the gap that
we're trying to fill
is, there's just not enough
easy tools for people
to use for those different
use cases right now.
But it really depends
on the information,
on the platform,
again, who you're
talking to-- the audience.
But I think the
average consumer,
they don't think about
long-form, short-form.
Was this useful?
Helpful?
Entertaining?
Funny?
So it's really just
about the content.
TYSON EVANS: And also, I
think the idea that there's
a canonical form
for a given story
anymore is totally
discarded at this point.
Really good stories have to
exist in somewhere between two
and six forms at this point.
There's the Facebook
version of the story,
there's the Twitter
there is the phone version
while you're on the run.
And that's not often how we
think of as content creators.
That this really
compelling story
needs to exist in
very alternative ways
based on the context of the
user that encounters it.
We think about,
this story deserves
to be 8,000 words
with 16 photos.
And we have to find ways to have
a lot more elastic definition
around those stories.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: A
really recent example
of that is actually
the Giants riots.
There were a bunch of
singular photos on Instagram.
They were taken on
Valencia or Mission.
Things were on fire.
But then there was a
bold, italic article
that came afterwards that
kind of editorialized
a couple of these photos,
as well as YouTube videos,
and kind of grouped it together.
So people individually
were telling their stories.
And then the bold
italic around that
told the story of the
night that happened.
And as you were
following on Twitter,
you could follow
this account which
was like @ScannerSays which was
the police scanner where you
could see live like where
a couch was on fire.
So there were all these
parallel story tracks
that are going on that
eventually get rounded up
in a piece of editorial.
DUSTIN SENOS:
Currently, Medium is
looked at very much
as the place to come
publish long-form,
thoughtful stories.
And we're trying to break that
because that's an intimidating
thing.
And not everything needs to be
long and a very polished piece.
And we're looking at things
like, I read a full book
on my iPhone without
thinking about it.
And it's because I
can be interrupted
and I can come back
to it at any point.
That doesn't exist
on the web yet.
There's no way of me reading a
three hour long read on the web
and come right back to it
and pick up where I left off.
And that's something we're
very interested in breaking.
And Circa is doing an
interesting job with this,
with letting stories
build up over time
and you can follow along.
And we're looking at ways of
enabling publishers to do that.
So, I could read a
serialized book on Medium
that comes out with a
new chapter every month.
That would be a very
interesting way to do it.
Just like we do with TV shows.
We don't see that
with writing yet.
I think it's an
interesting place to go.
RACHEL BEEN: It's
interesting with Medium.
I don't know, I wouldn't call it
necessarily sort of an apology.
But you put seven minutes.
This is how long the
story's going to take.
This is how long that we are
going to consume your time.
What was the original
intention behind that?
To almost apologize
for being long-form?
DUSTIN SENOS: We currently
have an A/B test right
now showing that or
not showing that.
And on one hand, it's fantastic.
Because you know what
you're signing up for.
On the other hand, if I see a
40 minute read on my iPhone,
I'm not going to click on it.
So it's kind of setting the
stage for the content you're
going to click into.
But it could also
be like, if you
didn't know it was 40
minutes and you click
on it and you're
completely engulfed in it
and you're 10
minutes in and you've
lost track of time,
that's fantastic.
Versus, I don't have
40 minutes right now.
So, metrics went up
when we put that there.
It's a very curious thing.
It was a very simple
algorithm that we
used to calculate that number.
And we continue to
try to figure out
if it's actually a
good thing to show.
We continuously hear from
users that they love seeing it.
RACHEL BEEN: Interesting.
MARK KAWANO: I think it's
important to also talk
about what we
think the story is.
I think that rather than
the long-form short-form
distinction, I think
that some of us that
are working on the
platform side are realizing
that there's a story structure.
Whether it's a photo,
or a Medium post,
or a Storehouse story.
They're really
just participating
in a larger conversation where
the story's been created.
The Giants winning the
World Series is the story.
And now I'm just participating
in that conversation,
maybe through my own story
or my own perspective.
But what is the real thing?
What is the real story?
How can I get involved with it?
And I think that how
that line is getting
blurred is also
really interesting
with these user-generated
content tools that we now have.
And a lot of times,
the story is broken
by the professional
at the New York Times.
But we all shift the story
as we give our opinion,
show our view of the
world because of that.
And that's been one of the
most interesting things that's
happened over the last few
years with media I think.
RACHEL BEEN: I want to
talk a little bit also
about technology in terms
of how that sort of changed
the way that we
were storytelling.
Obviously, storytelling,
long tradition.
But are there things
that are happening really
contemporarily that are altering
the way that storytelling
is being told and
changed and altered?
DUSTIN SENOS: Totally.
Bandwidth continuously going up.
Larger phone screens.
High resolution.
The fact that we can serve
beautiful typefaces now
on the web has really
opened up the doors
recently for us to really
raise the ceiling of what
can be published.
RACHEL BEEN: How
are you guys seeing
that video is being used?
Mark, it was interesting when
we were talking originally
about Storehouse, how
people are using video
in kind of a different
way from traditionally,
specifically watching a video.
Why do you think
that's happening?
MARK KAWANO: I think it's a
lot just what mobile has done.
And it's just made
us all have to be
a little bit more
efficient about how
we consume information.
About how we want to
share information.
And I think video is just one
of the most efficient ways
to give a window
into what's going on.
And it's very different
from a photo where you're
choosing the cropping and
the filtering, all that.
Video is much rawer
unless you edit it down.
Which is not the
typical type of video
that people put into Storehouse.
And I think it's
really fascinating
to see all these
different use cases.
You can describe it one
way, or you could just
watch someone do it, or
watch something happening.
That's kind of the way
our brains are processed.
Being animals, we can
deal with that much more
of a cognitive load
when it's visual.
RACHEL BEEN: Tyson, in terms
of technology at the Times,
has it been hard to
kind of push through?
It's a fairly old institution
to instigate that sort of change
on the digital side.
TYSON EVANS: Yeah.
Some of our biggest
challenges aren't
the reader-facing experience.
They're the internal tool set.
How can we tell really
complicated stories
in a more granular way?
Is the 800 word story
the go-to story form?
Probably not, but that's what
our tools are shaped toward.
And that's why tools like
Medium are fascinating.
Because you're taking apart this
idea that this is going to get
translated.
You're just working
right on the live site.
And those are huge
questions we have now
when it comes to aggregation,
live events, really complicated
long-running events
like the war in Syria.
How do we break
those down and create
tools that help piece
smaller pieces back together?
And maybe are even aware
of what you've read,
what you haven't read,
where you came from.
Those are all
technology problems.
And it's one of the biggest
reasons we've now got way
more developers and
designers sitting
next to journalists,
editors, reporters.
RACHEL BEEN: Mike, from
the Pitchfork side.
You have a small team,
but you iterate and play
with new technologies and ways
of presentation really quickly
and get a lot of the
cover stories out.
Why has that been enabled?
Why is that so easy to do
in a place like Pitchfork?
MICHAEL RENAUD: I don't know.
I think it's because
we're pretty nimble.
We are a small team.
There are four
developers, and including
myself, four designers.
So we do the festival, all
the sites, the print magazine,
we have our own CMS.
Actually, our
website is probably
the thing we forget
about most of the time.
We haven't designed
it in four years.
But we kind of work as we go.
What inspires us,
what's coming up next.
And we all just really
love what we do.
We love music.
So, it's mostly our passions
that drive what we do.
And I think because there's
not a huge bureaucracy.
We would love more developers,
but at the same time,
it's really easy to
communicate with us
and just get things
done as we go.
RACHEL BEEN: From an
Instagram perspective,
how do you think video has fared
on Instagram as a platform?
We were talking about
this a little bit
in terms of why
hasn't it becomes
as successful as the photo part?
MAYKEL LOOMANS: The medium
of video is really hard.
Actually lining up a shot,
it's really easy to mess it up.
There's like a pan, or
like a little twitch in it.
Then if you have some
level of self-curation
you won't post it.
There's obviously still
technological constraints
where you have very fast
broadband mobile internet
connections, but they're
still not fast enough.
And people tend to
just go past it.
You really have to like
swipe down and realize,
oh that was a video?
And then go back up.
Which is why I think that
consuming video is still not
as optimal as we want it to be.
Then to the storytelling
aspect of it,
it's really hard to tell a
story with one, two, three cuts.
It's really way more easier to
let the reader or the consumer
of the story look at a photo
and kind of fill in the blanks
there.
Whereas in a video you
constrain their story
that they would
come up with down.
Because there's obviously the
story that you tell, but then
there's also the story
that gets consumed.
There's a big difference there.
RACHEL BEEN: So I just
want to end-- we only
have a few minutes left
to talk about the future
of storytelling.
I'm curious to hear what
your products are doing
that's really pushing the
envelope in an interesting way.
And what do you
see in the future
for your particular products?
But specifically in
design, what are you
doing from a design
perspective that's
really pushing storytelling?
DUSTIN SENOS: So we joke
around that the original form
of storytelling was scrolls.
Than we did book binding.
And now we went back to
scrolling browsers again.
We kind of went all the
way back to the beginning.
And if you look at
things like games,
like checkers versus
the modern video games,
the leap is ginormous.
Why hasn't that happened with
telling stories online, or just
telling stories in general?
I see a future that stores are
much more immersive, much more
elaborate.
And they don't take a whole
bunch of work to create them.
You can just tell a
story and the tools
are there to really
help you push that.
Internally, we are just a
bunch of scrappy builders.
We just love building stuff.
We're continuously exploring
different directions.
And the version of
Medium we use internally
is very different than
the external version
because we try different
prototypes and experiments
constantly.
We're constantly building
small apps and just exploring.
We haven't figured it out yet.
We are looking
for people to help
us do that and kind of push the
limits of how you tell stories.
But what we have
today, and the products
that we're seeing
today, I don't think
are close to what
we'll see very soon.
RACHEL BEEN: What is
the Times going to do?
Is it going to change
the journalistic model?
TYSON EVANS: Yeah.
I think the big question is
what I was speaking to earlier,
the idea of adaptive
storytelling.
We need to find ways to shape
stories, the news, to readers.
Where are they?
What is their archetype?
What do they read?
How do we use the data we know
about them in a smarter way?
There's a lot of
really crude ways
to make that experience
feel personalized.
But I think the way to
do it in a way that's
intelligent and smart
and actually anticipates
what a user needs to
know about a given story
is our next biggest challenge.
But it's also a challenge
that's off-a-cliff big.
MARK KAWANO: If you think
about video, what we were just
talking about, there's still
big technological constraints
on why it hasn't
been adopted more.
Bandwidth is still not really
fast all over the world.
And we're now getting
higher quality video cameras
and learning how to shoot videos
and take videos and photos.
It's still so early on.
But I think a lot of us here
see the writing on the wall,
that it just makes sense
for a lot of different types
of stories to get more visual.
To use video in more
interesting ways.
And we're just kind of
at the start of that.
The very, very early innings.
And so I think we're just going
to see a lot more of that.
MAYKEL LOOMANS: I think that
one of the things that we will
probably see going
forward is that there
will be this thread that
will be the basic story.
And then everything else that
is only tangentially related
to it we'll start
getting access to.
Originally, obviously,
the internet
was designed to be a
link between documents.
So how can we start
linking this central story
to all these
sub-stories and go out?
I think Medium has a nice
feature there where you
can comment in line.
And you can actually
have a whole discussion
or conversation
next to a paragraph
or next to a sentence.
I think that if we kind
of explored that and look
at like photography or video
or other visual means that
could kind of blast
out from one paragraph
and show the story
of that paragraph.
I think the combination
of all these stories
is going to be like something--
RACHEL BEEN: Closing
thoughts, Mike?
MICHAEL RENAUD: Yeah,
all that stuff is great.
And I think that side
of things-- users
being involved,
video integration.
Even your own atmosphere
and your own experiences
being involved in
a story is huge.
And we'll explore
that as it goes on.
But we're also really grasping
at the traditional journalism
model.
A place where people
can go to trust a voice.
And so, I think, while at
the same time letting people
sort of create their own content
or being involved in the story
they're reading is
excellent, I think
just sticking with
tradition in a lot of ways
and really trying to hold
on to a lot of things that
seem to be slowly
slipping away is
going to continue to be really
important for us in the future.
RACHEL BEEN: Well,
we're out of time.
Does anyone have any closing
questions before we go?
I guess not.
Well, thank you, guys.
Thank you for joining
us on the panel.
[APPLAUSE]